I was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about about your approach
there in terms of you know what did you
want the clothes for each of the three
leads to say about them and to tell us
about them well you know like Barbara
said it always starts with the script
and Quinten script is like no other
script I've ever read just in terms of
the attention to detail and how richly
layered these characters were and you
know this is my first time working with
Quentin unlike these guys down here but
one of the things that I admire so much
about his work is he has created his own
visual language that's very stylish and
this I feel is his most repeting film
and yet I wanted to you know you read
like when reading the script there's
certain things that were mentioned in
the script that are part of the
Tarantino kind of vernacular like the
Hawaiian shirt and you know Rick wearing
the leather jacket but it the great
thing about working with him is it was
such a discovery in terms of you know we
didn't know really what the Hawaiian
shirt would look like you know that what
the color was and you know it started
with the script and and the way that
these character is so beautifully
detailed on page and then really it was
just a matter of lots of discovery and
you know and and the the juxtapose
juxtaposing cliff and Rick as the
support guy and this you know 50 60 s
cowboy actors found himself kind of
almost redundant in 1969 and then of
course Sharon so it's so interesting
working on a script where you have two
fictional characters in the center of
real-life events and real people so it
was a juiciest project for me for a
costume designer is so fantastic mark
what's your process on the next couple
readings in terms of what sorts of
things are you thinking about what are
you thinking ahead to in terms of
problems you might have
movie like this on location with Quentin
I try not to use the word problem I
always look at it as opportunity because
he is very I mean it's all about
character character their development
and and believing in those characters
for the audience so character takes us
to the journey the characters on and the
environment the character is having that
journey in and through that his his I
would say dedication to to performance
enables a really great collaboration on
the set if anything is threatening
performance or breaks connection with
character on the set then we're then
we're in a totally part in any situation
so for me that first read of the script
as a journey myself so I can be inside
the mind of the movie and not be in any
sort of technical concerns gets followed
up by an intense combing through in the
second and third reads for for things
that are our questions you know what
what what options can we bring here I
try not to bring an ideology to it
because even though we work together on
a repeated basis every projects
different and it's it's really important
not to come to with some a predetermined
idea and with Quentin especially because
he will throw curve balls at you every
turn but there are the kinds of
curveballs that really bring you up to
your your better place you know there
there come on come on come with me you
know and so that's that that's what I
bring to here and because there's such a
community of people around Quentin that
have been there like Fred and we joined
the family some of us have been working
and making movies together for 25 30 40
years and and and so when you get it's
like it's like a jazz band there there's
just this this joy and and Quentin is
its old school that he has this
repertoire company behind him and it
frees him up to be in focus with his
actors and with his scenes and and knows
that he's got that support around him so
it's a privilege I just want to sing
Marc's praises for a moment because one
thing that vit he's not gonna say
himself but that I'll say is that
Quentin doesn't do ADR so when he
decides to shoot
a scene between Brad Pitt and Margaret
quale in a car driving down the freeway
with the windows open mark has to figure
out a way to get a good recording of
that I don't know how he did it
and certainly our post-production sound
team helped but there was no ADR again
it's it's not about the sound it's about
connection to the characters and and so
that's really about proportion balance
you know not too much not too little are
we connected to them as characters will
the audience believe you know and and
once you have that as your threshold
versus you know some you know
theoretical thing then you then you have
you know you've got a road map and and
if we break into that that's a
conversation cue where you know there's
I'm concerned here we might be losing
connection and he listens to that he you
know because it's it's where he lives
and he invites us to join him there and
that's fantastic
the issue of character and performance
leads me to a question for Fred which is
how you see your role in terms of sort
of showcasing the best that the actors
bring to the movie I mean I'm I as I
understand it
Tarantino doesn't shoot a lot of
coverage or multiple cameras or any of
that kind of stuff but it seems to me
from watching the movie like he allows
us actors to be very playful and I'm
wondering if you get a lot of variations
on things and how you calibrate that and
and you know what you see your part has
in terms of cutting performance I mean
he he definitely doesn't shoot multiple
cameras he shoots the covers that he
wants so you know the action will have
more coverage than than a dialogue scene
but but um you're you're you have this
amazing cast and they're actually pretty
dialed in by the time they get to the
set there there's there's not there's
really no improv unless Quentin has
specifically designed a scene to be in
profit or II like this is the scene
where where rick has his freak out in
the trailer after he blows his lines on
set
that was that was Quentin kind of saying
Tulio I want you to hit these specific
beats but I'm not going to give you the
dialogue
I just kind of want you to do it and he
shot it from the same angle for takes
and and then it was kind of up up to me
and and then Quentin to kind of put it
together in the editing room and find
what beats we wanted but you know with
this cast I mean there's there's not a
false beat in there so it was really
just finding what's what's the what
angles do we want to be on to bring out
the emotion as much as possible I have
to ask you Barbara really quickly about
the Hollywood Boulevard makeover because
I live off Hollywood Boulevard and I
woke up one day and walked my dog and
suddenly it had turned into 1969
overnight and I'm curious how
logistically you did that I mean what
goes into how many months of work going
to that kind of quote-unquote instant
transformation I wish it was that
instant that it was overnight but no CGI
no CGI no that was a Hollywood Boulevard
was was tough and it was also a pretty
amazing that the Hollywood Chamber of
Commerce and the City Council's
said yes to what we were doing and that
again I give besides Rick Schuler our
location manager I give big credit to
Quentin because he went down to that
meeting and looked at them and said I
passionate about Hollywood I'm
passionate about showing it back you
know this is to me the where all of my
brain came from and they gave us it in
two sections they said you can't do all
that you want to do in one shoot so they
we took two blocks both sides which is
four blocks by musso's first we were and
then months later we could shoot the
other side so we actually split it up
because we would have we already had the
worst traffic jam ever we would have had
the worst traffic jam in the entire city
ever if we had taken the whole thing so
and that transformation was working very
heavily locations again I can't even
believe how many people they had to have
to go to each individual
storefront all the people who owned
everything on that block get the
permissions in the meantime we tried to
build we designed everything and tried
to build as much as we could off-site
and then worked out almost like you know
an army of you know engineers how
construction would go in first with
cranes put facades back on the movie you
know and then paint after that and then
you know working in stages and then my
decorator Nancy Haig who had her entire
battalion were the last layer to go in
and they only had really two short days
to actually tear out everything inside
of stores uh gnarled facades and dress
the entire thing and electricians
working on top I mean it was a really
and we could never not have tourists
that one thing they says is no never we
have to be able to have it's the most
heavily toward street I've ever seen by
the way and I'm from LA and I had no
idea that tourists were there 24 hours a
day so you had a battery of people
helping the tourists not run into all of
our stuff as they did tried to take
selfies of things and then smash into
the so we stopped no tourism they got to
be there with us building and watch it
which actually was pretty fun for them I
want to thank you all for coming out and
talking with us about it it's a great
movie thanks guys